here we go scientists create cyborg
jellyfish with a device that helps them
swim three times faster by sending
electric jolts through their body I'm
sorry this is one of the stupidest
stories I've ever seen why why but I was
so excited by it I I was I wouldn't I
was insistent that we would actually
read it so so scientists for some reason
thought that we should take a jellyfish
and give it motorized locomotion to
increase its speed they their life is
just floating along they're barely alive
they're barely life big just like their
life their turtle food I'm enjoying
myself
let's put engines on them right wait now
read the story hold on so I'm curious I
guess I should just read it what is this
the team designs a micro electronic
prosthetic that helps the creature swim
three times faster than their unmodified
counterparts while using less metabolic
metabolic energy the device is about two
centimeters in diameter and it is
attached to the body with a small wooden
barb okay okay hold on what jellyfish
are like the pigeons of the sea so first
of all they're ubiquitous they're
everywhere yet they're also right before
parity there are simple silly creatures
another dangerous like they can be the
most dangerous thing about a pigeon is
that poops on you but jellyfish are just
like bags of water that like flop around
so someone got the bright idea to strap
a motor to it and see what happens
well no no read it read more explain to
us let's suppose how does the jellyfish
engine work the researchers involved
evolved the product plan to equip the
jellyfish with sensors so they can
explore and gather information about the
ocean really make sense okay so they're
turning them into a little like you know
that's kind of creepy that's creepy
though man it's kind of creepy yeah but
what why mess with the jellyfish I don't
understand it's like they're not robotic
they're not cyborg no no it's simple
they're actual jellyfish so here's the
way I see it now not now I kind of
understand see we jumped the gun on
laughing at the scientists and their
stupid jellyfish project
they put the sensors on the jellyfish
the jellyfish can then collect
information as it floats about problem
is they're too slow so they need to give
the the jellyfish electric motors to
become cyborg jellyfish that could swim
faster and collect information faster I
honestly don't think we'll get a full
segment out of this story but it was so
ridiculous it's it's ridiculous I
couldn't help I couldn't help but laugh
at the stupid idea of a motorized
jellyfish so it says here the lead of
the study says only five to ten percent
of the volume of the ocean has been
explored so they want to take advantage
of the fact that jellyfish are
everywhere already to make the leap from
ship based measurements which they're
which are limited in number to to the
high costs so you know it I guess if you
it's making more sense as we watch Rick
and Morty I have seen a lot of the show
but I you see that you see the one where
he puts the cap on the dog and the dog
becomes smart yes I have seen that one
look what he'll you hath wrought
scientists you will regret this day when
the jellyfish uprising occurs but you
know it's actually creepy about
jellyfish they're pretty incredible well
no no it's it's our overfishing mm-hmm
the jellyfish are replacing so basically
like humans are disrupting the food
chain mm-hmm and so we're fishing out
all of these fish that typically would
like eat jellyfish yeah and then when
the fish are gone the jellyfish just
keep reproducing and then start taking
over mm-hmm his work gets gross now
people are eating the jellyfish I guess
nature finds a way right I mean is there
nutrients in them
it basically bags of water why are you
eating it well I don't know why do you
eat iceberg lettuce yeah 90% water would
you eat a jellyfish or no no cuz it's an
animal because it's an animal yeah yeah
but it's barely an animal it's just like
a bag of water that doesn't matter it's
a bag of water that Reaper didn't fight
the animal still I probably wouldn't eat
jellyfish what's up well let's let's see
if there's any more to the story let's
let's go down they say if we can find a
way to detect those these jellyfish and
also equip them with sensors to track
things like ocean temperature salinity
oxygen levels and so on we be create a
truly global ocean network where each of
the jellyfish robots costs a few dollars
to instrument and feeds themselves
energy
and from prey already notion I gotta say
I got a stop I feel really dumb making
fun of their jellyfish motors me too
this sounds really smart it does it's
like why should we build a bunch of
robots that float around the ocean when
there's things that float around the
ocean already yeah just you know you
know a little you know you know was what
Darwin here one of the funniest things
ever ever heard what the ocean was from
Joe Rogan uh-huh
on his podcast he was like he asked
somebody was talking but like Hawaii and
surfing and maybe it was Tulsi I don't
know and he was like no I'm scared of
the ocean like aren't you scared of the
ocean and they're like no why he's like
cuz there's a whole bunch of stuff out
there that moves a lot a lot better than
you and I was it was that how did he say
he said it funnier I mean I'm not a
comedian he's a comedian is funny no but
he was a really good point I'm like well
that's a really interesting way to think
about it like you're in the water and
you're like I can't move and then also
this thing shoots straight at you you're
like what are you gonna do yeah there's
more to this story let's uh let's let's
let's see what else we got so they say
oh this is interesting look at this the
prosthetic is coated in a waterproof
plastic film and house with the with
cork weights to keep it neutrally
buoyant the technology consists of a
mini processor lithium polymer battery
and two electrodes with LEDs to visually
indicate stimulation I I got it I got a
stop could you imagine being a fish and
you're like chilling and then all of a
sudden this flashing cyborg jellyfish
zooms at you three times faster than
normal
no better yet from a human perspective
could you imagine if you were like
walking around and also you saw a
squirrel with like metal plates on its
body and it just like jumped 50 feet in
the air
cyborg squirrel yeah that is a
frightening premise yeah like could you
imagine if aliens were like we're gonna
attach motors to birds to make them fly
10 times faster you see supersonic birds
like bursting into flames because the
friction created let's see we got this
it kind of cool though the jellyfish use
a pulsing motion to swim what is this to
swim come on get a copy editor which
moves them about two centimeters per
second they do this is America is a
British publication they're gonna be
metric the the team is using an electric
pulse to thrust the creatures faster
through the water which they compared to
a cardiac pacemakers it's kind of cool
the animals pulsing sped up producing a
corresponding increase in their swimming
speed to around four to six centimeters
per second
the jolts were also found to help them
swim more efficiently as they used just
twice as much energy to do so as
measured by the amount of oxygen
consumed by the animals while swimming
in fact the prosthetic equipped
jellyfish were over a thousand times
more efficient than swimming robot ok
that's actually pretty cool also kind of
scary
jellyfish are gonna come take over we've
shown that they're capable of moving
much faster than they normally do
without an undue cost on their
metabolisms who says there's more to
this story's ridiculous this reveals
that jellyfish possess an untapped
ability for faster more efficient
swimming
they just don't usually have a reason to
do so so what they're doing in efficient
slow so whatever you know there's
actually a funny point made in b-movie
classic b-movie uh the bee was asked
like why doesn't he fly everywhere and
he's like why don't you run everywhere
and I like that's a good point like
pigeons are hilarious because just kind
of like hobble yeah and you're like dude
you can fly it's like yeah but flying is
exhausting man like do you run now you
just walk you don't gotta fly guts uh
let's let's rap a story I never say in
be movie don't don't see it okay I want
the team also knows that jellyfish are
not harmed by the pulses these creatures
do secrete of mucus when stressed but no
such secretion was observed in this
experiment well that's good and I also
secrete mucus when stressed as do many
humans it's a joke don't leave that face
and the jellyfish went back to swimming
normally once the prosthetic was removed
okay I'm you know what I love this idea
you know be cool what if like aliens
came to earth mm-hmm now that we're
talking about aliens like we were in the
beginning and just like took a human and
strapped crazy technology that we didn't
understand and all of a sudden you were
smarter faster you know this was a
Twilight Zone episode was it yeah yeah
like - it was like two robots from the
future or something we're invisible
maybe was aliens and they made a guy
like they were screwed with a guy making
him really strong and then seeing how
would react that'd be pretty cool
interesting I kind of wonder like
sometimes cuz humans kind of act like
like these jellyfish have no idea we
even exist
they even perceive anything other than
like we're eating small things and
floating about and then all of a sudden
one day they have like super powers
relative to the jellyfish no jelly
they fight each other you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna I'm gonna tack on
just another little tidbits to this
segment now that we're talking about
giving inferior life-forms powerful
technology powerful what do you think
would happen if we went to like you know
you know those you know North Sentinel
island is mm-hmm it's where there's a
it's an uncontacted tribe and it's like
where is it like India or something like
off the coast of India or something
uncontacted tribe ons island and it's
apparently illegal to contact them but
whenever like helicopters fly by they
start like throwing spears and firing
arrows and they've never had kind of
there's also like Amazon tribes how can
they see the helicopter though because
you told me about the Native Americans
and I think it's for Columbus's is it's
a big different when a giant green
dragon is ten feet and you it's like wow
you're like I know and like I should
memorize you know but but basically you
know they've never had contact but
they're gonna fire arrows at you what do
they would happen if you under those
people just gave him like I don't a K
just like here's it here's an ak-47
clips the ready to go we think they
would do with it I mean they don't know
what a gun is so though they figure it
out
they'd be like if I point this at my
enemies they see they die instantly I
think it was magic mm-hmm
but they go nuts with it like if you
went to a non-contact Amazon tribe and
like here's massive technology bad
things happen it's so so basically I
bring this up cuz like talking about
aliens why they wouldn't come and grant
us technology overtly is because if you
give a human ridiculous powers they're
gonna get corrupt with it you have to
have to a lot of the culture to evolve
into the tech so like okay think about
it right now if all of a sudden an alien
came down and they said here's this
bracelet and when you wear it you can
point at anyone and they'll just boom
this cease to exist no evidence nothing
just gone that's frightening
how many people would abuse that kind of
technology way too many people yeah they
just feel like oh I can get rid of that
my enemy and no well no and I can go do
evil things not everybody most people
would be like no I can't do it I'm gonna
hurt somebody even if I don't like them
some people would go nuts with it or
better yet if you gave them tax that a
lot to him like you know in make them
impervious or like levitate stuff man
they go evil dictator overnight sorry
but I could see that so it's kind of
interesting there was the
this vein there was a story someone told
me when I was working advice about this
village in Saudi Arabia that was super
poor so they were all very much like
living in 1800s well water ready clothes
and they found oil also in this village
was super rich so what happened they
started buying golden statues of
themselves they were all wearing like
just ridiculous amounts of Rolexes and
just spending money on dumb things and
they looked ridiculous yeah and that's
what happens when they all of a sudden
get access to all this crazy stuff they
wouldn't nuts with it
mm-hmm and this guy told me this is why
poor people wouldn't he said this is why
poor people are poor they win the
lottery what do they do they buy golden
statues of themselves yeah we don't know
the money but there's no like
understanding of the power in their
hands there's no responsibility right
and so it's similar to like the tech I
don't know how somehow we got onto the
subject after talking about jellyfish
but I do think it's kind of fun yeah oh
yeah we were talking about jellyfish but
we're talking about being a superior
life-form giving inferior life-form
advanced technology to compete hmm man
think about this too like there's other
life there's other life in the ocean
fighting for food right now we're given
the jellyfish a leg up they do not
understand what they're doing now it's a
silly story the jellyfish will collect
data for us yeah but now they're gonna
outperform their competition by three
times the speed it's gotta have an
evolutionary impact right absolutely
we're messing with things we don't
understand I mean I don't care it's a
jellyfish I'm just saying you know what
the ocean is it's like the lungs of our
planet like we really need to reevaluate
it's not the Amazon rainforest or the
lungs of our planet and it's not true
actually most Oh most of our ocean comes
in the ocean from and carbon dioxide -
yeah when the oceans heat up carbon
dioxide comes in
you